[Music]
there she is guess what daddy is gonna
get you in transfer school today
we are descendants of the gods Aslan was
always ours but we must never relent or
nowhere and everywhere
you're from Virginia right I can tell
you're special we are the future
[Music]
you're not like the others
[Music]
whoever you were before that's over
[Music]
what are we doing what is the plan
[Applause]
it's okay
Oh
[Music]
I don't why you came all the way up here
there's nothing left
there are people out there worth saving
people that are left another kind of
people weren't saving so you got there
oh it's just my wife Emma it's my son
Charlie joy a lot less well last nothing
happier than the wife of a new detective
it was cool man she's different you know
my wife woman 600 Tuesdays and ain't
worth three Saturday nights how much
money you got a lot how many problems
you got a lot how many people detective
banks in route
whoever did this has another motive
[Music]
the targeting cops
this shit's gonna go sideways fast
somebody's out there po no space
you want to play games [ __ ]
what's the last thing you remember Danny
he said we had to route the reason you
survived it's because you're a very
uncommon girl you're not alone not
anymore
do you know a mutants or would anyone
like you she had their first time brain
I was 13 I thought she was a dream
I just lost control Sam actually started
panicking people got hurt
Roberto my girlfriend partner Viviana
I killed 18 men one by
[Music]
there's no hospital it's a cage
[Music]
it's important we find out your collar
so we can help you get better I saw
something I don't think she wanted me to
see
[Music]
I'll think we're here to cut better this
place takes your greatest fear it makes
you live through it until it kills you
he's there we can get out of this
together
[Applause]
[Music]
what is storytelling storytelling
started with our indigenous people can
anyone give me an example of a myth or a
story they're afraid of Lucas found a
part of a man in the woods today part of
a man I guess the other half was found
in the mine all this has got to be an
animal right
[Music]
no animal I've ever seen something is
going on with Lucas
these drawings belongs to a student of
mine this is what was in the mind it's
what diabolical spirit this is a myth
for you yeah
Malcolm engage a police again
he's not your responsibility
he has my responsibility
he's here
[Music]
you
[Music]
dr. hunt
[Applause]
[Music]
you get the truck come back with the
money that's two point five million
dollars per head if you come back alive
[Music]
kobish compiled
I just took it on Tommy
[Music]
cosmetics
Tadasana
yeah
Michael I've known you since you were a
child me the gift
you always have if there's an answer to
the disease you'll find it
I should have died years ago
why am I still here if not to fix this I
have a rare blood disease and I'm
running out of time
this could be my last chance
you're up to something what is it
that's not exactly label
I don't want to see you get hurt more
than you already have this would be a
cure
at what cost
[Music]
I went from time
of increased strength his speed
the ability is echolocation
and then overpowering nerds to consume
blood
[Music]
how far are we allowed to go
we'll fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease
Michael Morbius got tired of doing a
little good guy thing huh what's up doc
I'm Anna Fox there are some things that
need to be said about me I have an
anxiety disorder I'm not prepared for
visitors I'm a agoraphobic I can't go
outside
[Applause]
[Music]
you let some of the outside come in your
neighbor from across the street pretty
sure you're not supposed to be hippies
with alcohol
her name is Jane Russell she's become a
friend like your earrings oh thanks a
gift from an old boyfriend
does your husband in mind
[Music]
our family's complicated
I
[Music]
my neighbor changed she's been stabbed
you might be Dean why is he here
mr. Russell believes that you made a
mistake you have never met my wife we
spent the evening together I'm Jane
Russell she's not Jane I know what I saw
the doctor said that your meds
can cause hallucinations why are you
protecting them
they're all hiding something
her earring it's in their house you're
playing with the wrong family do they
know you're here alone
nine-one-one I think somebody hazing my
house don't go looking into other
people's houses you won't like what you
see there are many like you Tamas who
seek refuge you this is Magda mother
lives on the top floor she's very ill
why being young a builder right that's
what you said try to make things
bearable for them she needs
companionship but I won't like it
like that is young Thomas she could
become attached
[Applause]
what's wrong weekend it has to be this
way I'm afraid
[Music]
did you kill people in the world what is
happening to me do you know what a demon
is she belongs to it
how are you Tomas settling in
[Music]